and so what this does is you can create
in what I did I actually uh made a PAW
Patrol drill rap song and so that was my
uh my prompt was using the characters of
Paw Patrol make a you know breaking all
copyright violations here you got the
PAW Patrol IP you've got whatever
artist 50 in here I love it and so I'm
going to play this Seas
coming this game we got
theame back
[Music]
okay so oh yeah man I can see kids
digging that yeah and so now we've gone
from we saw in the YouTube video where
you you had to at least you know put the
lyrics in yourself write the lyrics this
is all just prompt based yes the music
is prompt and the lyrics are also
generated just on a theme full service
here AI what we call AI all the way down
all the way
down